[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je m'appelle Sophie Personna euh ma
petite entreprise mon nom de marque
c'est sophile de soie donc je suis dans
la couture depuis une dizaine d'années
et j'ai monté ma petite entreprise il y
a à peu près 1 an alors en fait j'ai
commencé à coudre quand j'ai eu mon
premier enfant puis j'ai eu envie de de
réaliser quelque chose pour lui donc
c'est comme ça que je suis venue à la
couture j'ai vraiment pris goût donc
j'ai appris sur le tas la majeure partie
des vêtements des accessoires que je
crée je crée mes propres patrons on
trace le patron sur un sur un papier on
découpe et à partir du patron on
commence à tailler le à tailler le tissu
donc une fois qu'on a taillé le le tissu
on commence par surjeter l'ensemble des
bords du tissu afin que déjà la couture
soit propre et que le tissu ne
s'effiloche pas après il y a la partie
assemblage qu' on va assembler le devant
et le dos pour faire les couture de côté
et puis après il y a la partie à
l'intérieur ce qu'on appelle la
parmenture qui va être assemblé le
devant et le dos après il y a la
réalisation des petites boutonnières
après il y a l' relet du bas donc sur
une robe comme ça on est à peu près sur
1 heure et dem de de travail moi c'est
vrai que je prends beaucoup de temps
pour choisir un tissu euh j'adore les
matières j'adore j'adore toucher le
tissu j'adore le je travaille
principalement avec le coton j'essaie
vraiment de mixer les différents types
de tissus de faire des associations euh
c'est rare que je fasse une pièce avec
un seul tissu euh c'est vrai que les
gens apprécient je crois un retour au au
travail fait main et j'accorde vraiment
une une grande attention aux finitions
donc l'accueil est en général très bon
et je me rends compte que les personnes
apprécient euh justement l'originalité
des tissus avec lesquels j'essaie de
travailler par rapport à la à la grande
distribution c'est vrai
que c'est la concurrence est parfois est
parfois difficile mais je crois que les
gens qui connaissent la véritable
qualité du travail à la main reviennent
finalement vers ces vers ce genre de
produit au moins pour se faire plaisir
pas dans la vie de tous les jours mais
au moins pour se faire
[Musique]
plaisir moi c'est quelqu'un d'origine de
la Grande Fontaine Saint-Paul ce t de
Ros quoi et là c'est un quartier
vraiment le capital des cocotiers on
trouve toute variété de cocotiers qui
existent la Réunion en voyant toutes les
toutes les feuilles de coco qui gaspill
de gauche à droite il ça de gauche à
droite me dit il faut valoriser ça en
fait tu vois et puis
TTI en regardant le cocotiers vu créer
mon métier dedans pourquoi aller dans ce
monde tressage par rapport parce que
comme il regarde
n savoir faire comment disparaît on
regard travers l'Î on peut créer
vraiment un
métier allez 4 ans La Réunion très beau
pays on a beaucoup de matière première
locale sur la main de gauche à droite
partout là seulement il manque les
objets pour les touristes en général
c'est un panier
multifonction on peut mettre le fruit
dedans une composition de fruits sinon
on peut mettre aussi dans la cuisine les
épices secs tel que les joignons la ça
les gens il connaisent pas aussi on peut
mettre aussi dans les salles de bain un
vide fosse donc là un qui tient le bloc
l'autre qui travaille comme ça utiliser
le doigt comme ça
avec mon dépous la main dessous comme ça
il ver
l'avantend suivant pareil le tour
suivant poignet
suivant
même là le panier les
fait faut le sens de la vente des
communication et c'est pas Mo des
commercial aussi ça va dans ce monde
artisanal allez pas faire semblant fais
rien petit il faut aller voir d' ch à
côté capable faire aussi quelqu'un qui
est capable faire cré son métier en
fait des
connaissan valoriser ça premièrement à
travers les Mar les et les écoles fleur
les hôtels tout ça et
puis monter le savoirfire au jeunes
futur qui comme ça oublie pas la culture
reste
là
[Musique]